so taking a look at this snippet of code
it looks like document click it's taking
in some kind of function we see function
then a parameter and then these curly
braces that are passing in while some
instructions this is similar to regular
function syntax or we declare a function
with the keyword function set some
parameters and then put code inside
curly braces but this function doesn't
seem to have a name and that's kind of
curious so let's go ahead and open up
Google I typed in JavaScript function
without name and I'm gonna take a look
at the results we came across an article
about JavaScript anonymous functions
this seam is really useful
it looks like an anonymous function is
one that's declared without a name that
sounds like what we've got so it looks
like document click is taking an
anonymous function as a parameter you'll
find anonymous functions all over the
place in JavaScript so I encourage you
to check out the resources in the
instructor notes to learn more about
them